pour avoir un corps musclé cet été
est-ce que c'est déjà mort
j'entends ça dire oui parce que les
recettes miracles c'est pas forcément
top merci
d'être passé allez alors on passe à
autre chose comment avoir un corps
dégueulasse pour cet été non mais non tu
penses non combien de temps il faut
alors moi juste avant de parler de ça je
veux juste qu'on peut le corps de rêve
le body summer je vais juste que tout le
monde soit bien clair que il faut
d'abord s'apprécier soi-même dans la
glace et c'est pas forcément ce qu'on
voit la télé ou dans les magazines qu'il
faut aller chercher mais dans la glace
parce que nous on s'apprécie devant une
glace
avec une glace donc toi tu te penses
c'est d'abord mentalement de accepter
soi-même et d'être de pas se mettre en
pression avec ça moi par exemple c'est
vrai que je suis complexé alors
merci c'est tout pour
[Applaudissements]
c'était Cyril Hanouna merci c'est tout
pour moi
c'est vrai que tu as raison on
s'accepter soi-même
il a raison Madrid il a raison non mais
c'est vrai d'abord c'est qui tu es bien
dans ta tête tu es bien dans ton corps
et tu es bien dans les autres est-ce
qu'il disait
exactement en fait on essaie on a un peu
des standards physiques déjà pour moi
écarter un peu ces standards et juste
regarder être Alice avec ce qu'on est
s'apprécie soi-même et après succès des
objectifs pour essayer d'évoluer vers là
où on a envie d'aller mais le mental
sera la base déjà mais si on s'accepte
pas le plus envie de se bouger en même
temps
mais sans s'accepte pas ça va donner ça
va être une motivation ça va être même
pourquoi pour aller chercher là où on a
envie d'aller en fait concrètement mais
faut pas se flageller en fait déjà faut
se détacher des standards pour moi faut
détacher des standards que la société
peu importe qu'on se met et parce qu'on
peut objective tous être on est tous bon
en fait chacun notre manière et
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire on est
tous beaux tous alors moi je vais quand
vous dites on est tous beaux je vais
surtout retenir chacun notre manière
[Applaudissements]
personnellement oui est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire qui est le plus beau
corps ici et qui a le corps le plus
éclaté au sol
j'ai rien compris
c'est celui qui se regarde dans la glace
qui dit je suis trop mais c'est
exceptionnel
merci non non mais tu veux je te dise
mais il a raison dans ce qu'il dit moi
je sais que c'est toi qui décide tu veux
que je te dise c'est toi qui décide même
dans la même dans la séduction si une
personne voit que tu es sûr de toi si tu
dis de toute façon c'est de l'auto
persuasion si tu dis je suis beau gosse
tu arrives à la plage si je suis beau
gosse même si tu es dégueulasse mais je
crois qu'il est beau mais tu es sûr
c'est vrai au début j'étais pas sûr et
là maintenant tu le dis je me dis
pourquoi pas en fait il y a un délire il
y a quelque chose non mais c'est vrai je
vous dis il a raison Adri tout est dans
la tête alors à part la tête quand même
euh le boulot
il y a quand même le premier truc c'est
se motiver
se motiver voilà toi Gilles
mais toi tu as un corps de javelot donc
c'est vrai que non mais c'est vrai tu
seras aux JO 2024 quoi non mais c'est
vrai que non mais non tu es encore tu
disais quoi de lâche tu as dit tout à
l'heure
magnifique
arrête arrête je t'ai vu ah oui c'est
vrai attendez vous quoi la balle de golf
rentrer dans ta raie quand même
lors d'un défi non mais toi tu es motivé
il me manque juste le déclic c'est pour
ça que je suis ça commence à faire parce
que
raffermir mais sinon voilà ton corps pas
du tout
tu vas à la salle j'ai pas le temps tu
vas juste à la salle des fêtes on va
il dit je bosse et tout mais voilà elle
elle aime bien voilà elle est un peu
du sport tout le temps donc mais je
l'accompagne
c'est Marius dans Les Bronzés allez
encore 20 km
franchement tu vas finir chez Faustine
Bolla
je te le dis je le sens gros comme une
maison ça non mais c'est bizarre quand
même elle te dit que tu es beau non
c'est pas mal moi je te dis elle dit
terminé les ganse tu as une élégance oui
oui oui
elle dit quoi
quoi votre meuf vous dites pas que vous
êtes beau
[Musique]
si tu m'as fait menteur c'est bon
j'ai dit complexe
[Applaudissements]
mais par rapport à l'ensemble de des
garçons ça va ça va
mais bon
ma mère te trouve beau
de merde
quand on le voit alors à part le petit
zizi sinon tout est parti non vraiment
voilà j'ai fait une photo de moi ce
matin dans la glace
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les vannes de daron
autour de la table Adri il faut bien
s'hydrater ouais donc comment je mets de
la crème non à feu en bois aussi mais
l'hydratation c'est important le corps
est fait de plus de 50 % d'eau 75 %
quelque chose comme ça ouais 75 % d'eau
je crois l'eau donc en fait il y a 60 %,
75% d'eau 25% de Pride
c'est pas de l'eau non stop
des morphologies mais l'eau c'est fin
c'est la base de la vie c'est la vie ma
société s'appelle H2O c'est pour le
liquide non mais je te dis
tonton tu fais chier tout le monde là
va voir tata en cuisine
il faut boire que de l'eau les sodas
c'est mauvais les sodas même sans sucre
personnellement je pense que j'ai après
je fais un diététicienne donc je peux
pas vous dire la composition on a des
sodas sans sucre mais pour moi ça pose
un problème à partir du moment c'est
quelque chose un produit retravaillé
donc j'ai de l'eau à volonté et les
produits laitiers sont toujours nos amis
pour la vie
évitez les produits transformés
je le dis tout le temps pour avoir un
corps musclé il faut faire attention à
son
alignementation si vous pratiquez du
sport que vous ne faites pas attention
bah ça ça fera peut-être
les produits transformés alors c'est
quoi les produits transformés mais les
pizzas les trucs tout tout transformer
en fait je peux le faire simple il y a
200 ans et on fait un peu plus même il y
a 1000 ans en arrière
toutes les maladies qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc en fait mangeons combien 1000 ans
et tout ce qui existait pas il y a 1000
ans ou 200 ans de vie aussi comme
aujourd'hui c'était plus par rapport à
la médecine ouais par rapport à la santé
on avait pas les problèmes qu'on peut
avoir aujourd'hui de cardio-vasculaire
j'ai remarqué un truc j'ai remarqué un
truc c'est que tout ce qui est bon et
mauvais c'est ça en fait que les trucs
dégueulasse que tu peux manger et tu dis
ouais c'est bien
mes enfants qui regardent la télé ils
vont pas être contents mais en fait dès
qu'il y a quelque chose qui a l'air bon
le mange pas exactement bah tu vois
c'est pour ça que Daniel on la mange pas
la santé
faut pas le manger non mais c'est ça qui
est fou donc ça veut dire tu tu tu
galères quoi ah il faut bien dormir
respecter les temps de récupération
est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui vous
empêchent de dormir où est-ce que vous
vous arrivez à ne parfois vous ne dormez
pas parce que vous êtes vous êtes
contrarié vous êtes d'accord jamais moi
jamais ça se voit frère parce que là
franchement tu étais là je te vois même
plus c'est et quand je dors un peu je me
réveille quelque chose dans la tête et
tout mais pourquoi dans la tête aux
mains le travail est-ce que fat tout va
bien est-ce que tout le monde va bien
est-ce que c'est est-ce que ça je me
lève je vais faire un café à n'importe
quelle heure je bois un verre d'eau je
fais je suis complètement déréglé dans
ma tête mais pas dans ta tête
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai pas trouvé le bail hein
bah il bosse bien il bosse bien
franchement
si vous pouvez me dire si je fais du
sport très tard le soir
donc c'est mieux le matin bien sûr sinon
ça rend insomniaque c'est ça bien sûr en
fin de journée en fait le le pic
d'ornement est vers aux alentours de 17h
mais le matin c'est bien un jeune ça
crée des des pages et tout ça quand on
est à jeunes
pour le corps le matin en tout cas c'est
sûr après 20h votre ça réveille votre
système cardio
après l'émission j'ai joué au tennis
genre 22 23
pas de la nuit c'est normal c'est un
petit peu ouais d'accord
[Musique]
mais il y a des études qui ont été
prouvées qui a à jeun ou avec de l'eau
il boire de l'eau pour réveiller le
corps de l'eau citronnée par exemple et
après une activité physique et comment
[Musique]
merci
et il faut surtout s'entraîner c'est ça
le truc et il y a pas un système
incroyable Adri toi tu es spécialiste de
l'électrostimulation
ah c'est ça il est spécialiste de
ça fait ça
non mais c'est vrai et je voyais mon
zizi
supportable pareil à pété
ça me fait peur c'est pas dangereux non
c'est pas dangereux alors c'est pas
dangereux non pas du tout de toute façon
si tu depuis par la médecine depuis
maintenant des années est-ce que ça fait
mal non après si tu dépends
l'utilisation qu'on en fait mais non
c'est une sensation qui surprenante qui
est différente mais non ça fait pas mal
et c'est absolument pas dangereux ici 25
minutes d'électrostimulation et qui voit
4 heures d'entraînement alors ça c'est
vrai ça c'est très simple je sais pas
s'il y a des je prends l'exemple des
hommes et ça des hommes qui ont la salle
de sport le lundi on travaille les pecs
le mardi le dos le jeudi
tout en même temps en une seule fois en
plus
il y a des contre dications il y a les
majoritaires qui vont être d'être
enceinte l'épilepsie un pays smaker et
après il y a tout un tas de petites
contre-indications qui ont demandé une
audience de médecin ou un avis médical
moi je l'ai fait bonsoir j'ai fait ça
pendant un petit moment alors
effectivement on a les fesses qui
remontent au niveau des omoplates c'est
vachement bien et quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on travaille pas en profondeur c'est
justement en profondeur on va travailler
plus de fibres musculaires on va
travailler ça en poussant la fibre
musculaire mais après c'est comme tu
taxis physique en fait si vous maintenez
pas le cas oui ils vont mieux faire un
petit peu longtemps comme beaucoup sur
une courte
ta vie ça casse donc ces électrodes sur
soi pendant genre 25 minutes tous les
soirs absolument pas
vous allez faire une contraction
volontaire qui va être amplifiée par le
travail de la machine donc il faut
travailler en fait il y aura le même
message non Ronal mais par contre c'est
pas dans la télé alors il y a
différentes choses qu'on peut faire il y
a des coachs à domicile nous on a des
choix on a fait des petits studios des
petites unités ou venez
avec trois machines et venir en petit
groupe faire vos activités votre séance
mais non c'est pas dans la télé c'est
pas le vendeur de rêve là où je suis
dans la télé en train de manger des
chips c'est
ça ça n'existe pas non Jean-Mi ça
n'existe pas
j'en ai fait un peu c'est vrai que
c'était un petit peu oui après on va
tout de suite
de se muscler les pieds lui alors le
principe de 250 sport et c'est parce
qu'on travaille le Coran chier c'est ça
après on peut cibler plus spécifiquement
certaines zones les gens qui veulent
perdre que des bras que du ventre ou que
des mais
on peut éteindre les électrodes on peut
avoir on peut éteindre un peu on perd un
peu l'intérêt
c'était travailler parce que sinon en
fait si on
veut mais non on mettra on mettra on va
adapter nos actions on va adapter en
fonction de l'âge en fonction de de la
volonté de la personne et on va pouvoir
vraiment adapter le l'entraînement en
fonction du besoin de la personne et de
ce qu'elle veut en fait c'est une séance
de sport mais multipliée quoi ouais moi
quand je présente je dis c'est une salle
de sport pour les feignants et ceux qui
ont pas le temps je crois que c'est
merci en tout cas merci tu tu dois
parler à demain
avec elle un coup de jus ça fait
des années
[Applaudissements]